This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the Bay area where I've lived for a couple of decades now, I've watched the front line of gentrification move further and further east. This show is based in Oakland, as you probably know, and Oakland is quite big and heterogeneous, so you can never really talk about it as one thing, but in the last couple years, Rents have been going up, and the fear is that rents will continue to go up to a point where only wealthy tech workers can afford it. This phenomenon is not unique to the bay.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在我居住了二十年的湾区，我目睹了士绅化的前线不断向东推进。正如你们所知，这个节目以奥克兰为基地，而奥克兰非常大且多元，所以你很难将其视为一个单一的整体。但在过去几年里，租金一直在上涨，人们担心租金会持续上涨到只有富有的科技工作者才能负担得起的程度。这种现象并非湾区独有。
East New York, a residential neighborhood on the Eastern edge of Brooklyn is going through this now too. In the 1960s, East New York rapidly transformed from a mostly white working class neighborhood to an underserved community of mostly black and brown New Yorkers neglected by both society and policy. But now as New York City rents skyrocket, East New York is staring down a wave of gentrification that will forever change the character of this neighborhood that 120,000 people call home.
位于布鲁克林东缘的住宅区东纽约（East New York）现在也正在经历这一切。20世纪60年代，东纽约迅速从一个以白人工薪阶层为主的社区，转变为一个被社会和政策双重忽视的黑人和棕色人种社区。但现在，随着纽约市租金飞涨，东纽约正面临着一波士绅化浪潮，这将永远改变这个拥有12万居民的社区的特质。
WNYC in New York and the Nation magazine have teamed up for an in-depth look at the gentrification of Brooklyn. They call their series, There Goes the Neighborhood. Today we're showcasing an episode from this ongoing series that's really fantastic. It turns back the clock and looks at how this new, rather unlikely hotspot for gentrification got to where it is today. This is episode three of There Goes the Neighborhood, Turf Wars, presented by Chi-Ride of the Nation magazine.
纽约的WNYC电台与《国家》杂志合作，深入探讨了布鲁克林的士绅化问题。他们将这个系列节目命名为《社区不再》（There Goes the Neighborhood）。今天，我们将展示这个正在进行的系列节目中非常精彩的一集。它回溯过去，审视这个新的、不太可能的士绅化热点是如何走到今天这一步的。这是《社区不再》的第三集《地盘之争》，由《国家》杂志的凯·赖特（Kai Wright）主持。
I could get a lottery. You're gonna sit there and have this year and take it to the country. You know what's interesting the other day I was walking in my neighborhood and I saw a black elderly gentleman That I hadn't seen in a couple months and he literally his eyes flew open and he said you're still here And I went yeah, and you're still here things have changed happened then and we were like yeah Black folks are disappearing. Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ, Jesus, Jesus Christ, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus Christ, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus When everybody gave up on the neighborhood, we didn't. We stood in the neighborhood.
我可以去抽签。你坐在那儿，把这一年带到乡下去。你知道吗，有趣的是，前几天我在社区散步时，看到一位我几个月没见的老年黑人绅士，他简直瞪大了眼睛说：“你还在这儿？”我说：“是啊，你也不也还在吗？事情变了，发生了变化。”我们当时就想：“是啊，黑人正在消失。”当所有人都放弃了这个社区时，我们没有。我们留在了社区里。
We worked it out, and we made it the better place that everybody wants to invest into now. We live on Bobby as family. We all live for each other. They have also the political power to modify. They can go and sit with commissioners and with high ranked people and say I need an extra block. I had a guy walking around my back y'all yeah I'm looking at my body's property I said we're looking for the property for my own. He says oh dude it's this is a four-course I said this
我们解决了问题，并把它变成了现在每个人都想投资的更好的地方。我们像家人一样生活在鲍比（Bobby）。我们都为彼此而活。他们也有政治权力去进行修改。他们可以去和专员以及高层人士坐下来谈，说我需要多一个街区。我有个家伙在我家后院走来走去，我说：“嘿，我在看我的房产。”他说：“我们在为我自己的房产寻找。”他说：“哦，伙计，这是四道菜。”我说……
and do you refuse. All I see is overpopulating the city with others. The only ones that got afforded this rent is people that's not from New York. Okay and and my income doesn't even give enough for a room in East New York, so how the hell is going to give me for apartment? There goes the neighborhood. I'm Kai Wright and I'm an editor at the Nation magazine and my WNYC colleagues and I have been looking at this major demographic change that's happening all over Brooklyn now. Gentrification is one term that's applied to it. And a lot of people who are sick of hearing that term feel like, hey, this is just the
你拒绝了吗？我只看到城市里挤满了其他人。唯一能负担得起这租金的人不是纽约本地人。好吧，我的收入甚至连东纽约的一个房间都租不起，那它怎么可能让我租得起公寓呢？《社区不再》。我是凯·赖特，我是《国家》杂志的编辑，我和我的WNYC同事们一直在关注现在整个布鲁克林正在发生的这种重大人口结构变化。士绅化是用来形容它的一个术语。很多听腻了这个词的人觉得，嘿，这只是……
law of supply and demand. There's relatively cheap property available and all things being equal, the people who can afford it grab it. And the people who had it earlier, they reap the rewards. But all things are not equal. They never have been. For decades, public policies stack the deck of economic opportunity against black people.
供需法则。这里有相对便宜的房产，在所有条件相同的情况下，负担得起的人就会抢购。而那些早先拥有它的人，他们获得了回报。但所有条件并不相同。它们从来没有相同过。几十年来，公共政策在经济机会上对黑人不利。
writer Tana Hasekot has spoken a lot about this fact lately, and making his case for economic reparations. He made the link to gentrification succinctly during a recent talk in Brooklyn. The neighborhood changed all the time in their makeup and their ethnic makeup. The problem is black people don't really have the same level of self-determination to decide whether they want to stay and whether they want to leave. When we built the middle class in this country, we made decisions about who was gonna benefit and we decided black people weren't a part of that.
作家塔-内西·科茨（Ta-Nehisi Coates）最近经常谈论这个事实，并为经济赔偿辩护。他在布鲁克林的一次演讲中简洁地将此与士绅化联系起来。社区的构成和种族构成一直在变化。问题在于，黑人并没有同样的自决权来决定他们是想留下还是想离开。当我们在这个国家建立中产阶级时，我们决定了谁将受益，而我们决定了黑人不包括在内。
When we get to the point of talking about gentrification, you got to dig deep, you got to go further back. So today we take a long look back at East New York. The Brooklyn neighborhood that as we started exploring last time is now standing right in the path of gentrification. The first developer to set his sights on East New York was Colonel John Picken, way back in 1835. His family got rich on cotton and slaves, but went broke in the cotton crash of 1837. It was a lot like 2008, but back then,
当我们谈到士绅化时，你必须深入挖掘，你必须追溯得更远。所以今天我们回顾一下东纽约。正如我们上次开始探索的那样，这个布鲁克林社区现在正处于士绅化的道路上。第一个将目光投向东纽约的开发商是约翰·皮特金（John Pitkin）上校，早在1835年。他的家族靠棉花和奴隶致富，但在1837年的棉花崩盘中破产了。这很像2008年，但在那时……
the bubble was cotton not-sumprime mortgages. Anyway, Pitkin lost his shirt in the crash, but not before launching this neighborhood into existence. He bought up a bunch of farmland, built a shoe factory, and called it East New York. Brooklyn's famous Pitkin Avenue still bears his name. The Long Island Railroad came about a year later, and with it, factories to process foods from Long Island's farms.
泡沫是棉花，而不是次级抵押贷款。总之，皮特金在崩盘中赔光了钱，但在那之前，他启动了这个社区的建设。他买下了一大片农田，建了一家鞋厂，并将其命名为东纽约。布鲁克林著名的皮特金大道（Pitkin Avenue）至今仍以他的名字命名。长岛铁路大约一年后开通，随之而来的是加工长岛农场食品的工厂。
The low-rise housing that still defines the area skyline came next, then more rail lines, connecting the area to Manhattan and the rest of Brookland, and it just kept growing all the way through the middle of the 20th century. East New York became a thriving suburb for the European immigrants who worked in all those factories. Germans and Italians and eventually Jewish families came here to feel, well, successful and American. It was sort of the suburbs in the city. It was a place where people strived to go. That's Ron Schiffman, a community organizer and urban planner who's been fighting the
定义该地区天际线的低层住宅紧随其后，然后是更多的铁路线，将该地区与曼哈顿和布鲁克林的其余部分连接起来，它在20世纪中叶一直保持增长。东纽约成为了在那些工厂工作的欧洲移民的繁荣郊区。德国人、意大利人，最终是犹太家庭来到这里，感到……嗯，成功且美国化。这有点像城市里的郊区。这是一个人们努力想要去的地方。那是罗恩·希夫曼（Ron Schiffman），一位社区组织者和城市规划师，他一直在战斗……
development wars in Brooklyn since the 60s. He grew up in Westchester, but spent a lot of time in East New York as a high school kid in the 50s. My first girlfriend actually was in East New York. I used to travel from Lower Westchester County to Beaver at the... It's a long commute, you must have been allowed. It was a long commute. She was a daughter of a judge lived in East New York. He paints an almost Norman Rockwell portrait of the place. It was attached housing, but everybody had their own porch. It was a middle-income, upper-middle-income community in many ways.
自60年代以来，布鲁克林的开发战争。他在威彻斯特长大，但在50年代作为高中生时，在东纽约花了很多时间。我第一个女朋友其实就在东纽约。我过去常从下威彻斯特县到比弗……那是一段很长的通勤路，你一定很执着。那是一段很长的通勤路。她是住在东纽约的一位法官的女儿。他描绘了一幅几乎是诺曼·洛克威尔（Norman Rockwell）风格的地方肖像。那是联排住宅，但每个人都有自己的门廊。在许多方面，这是一个中等收入、中上收入的社区。
We were aspiring community. It was not what we think of today. It was a white community. And then, all of a a sudden it wasn't. Over the course of just four or five years the neighborhood changed dramatically, from middle class to poor, from largely white to nearly all black. In 1960 East New York was 85% white. By 1966 it was 80% black and Puerto Rican. Why? What created such a stark change? A lot happened really fast, but there was a key moment.
我们是一个有抱负的社区。它不是我们今天所想的那样。它是一个白人社区。然后，突然之间就不是了。在短短四五年间，社区发生了巨大的变化，从中产阶级变为贫困，从主要是白人变为几乎全是黑人和波多黎各人。1960年，东纽约85%是白人。到1966年，80%是黑人和波多黎各人。为什么？是什么造成了如此巨大的变化？很多事情发生得非常快，但有一个关键时刻。
It happened on a hot summer night on July 21, 1966. That's the day an 11-year-old black boy was shot. Jim O'Grady has the story. Here's a little hint that East New York was primed for racial tension in the summer of 1966. Some of its citizens got together and started a little self-help group called Sponge, SPONGE, the Society for the Prevention of Negroes Getting Everything. Oh, 1966.
它发生在1966年7月21日一个炎热的夏夜。那天，一名11岁的黑人男孩被枪杀。吉姆·奥格雷迪（Jim O'Grady）报道了这个故事。这里有一个小提示，说明东纽约在1966年夏天已经为种族紧张局势做好了准备。它的一些公民聚在一起，成立了一个名为Sponge的小型自助组织，SPONGE，即“防止黑人获得一切协会”（Society for the Prevention of Negroes Getting Everything）。哦，1966年。
Of course, the group was white only. It's members part of the 20% of the neighborhood that hadn't become black or Puerto Rican. A neighborhood that is, Kai said, ethnic whites had dominated, demographically, economically, culturally, until as recently as five years before. Anthony Momino was a teenager when the changes came down. He was born in the United States. economically, culturally, until as recently as five years before.
当然，该组织仅限白人。其成员是社区中那20%尚未变成黑人或波多黎各人的部分。正如凯所说，直到五年前，族裔白人在人口、经济和文化上一直占据主导地位。安东尼·莫米诺（Anthony Momino）在变化发生时还是个少年。他出生在美国。经济上、文化上，直到五年前。
Anthony Momino was a teenager when the changes came down. He was born in Tunisia, but he's Italian. A lot of the whites in East New York were Italian. I remember where I lived, and it was mostly all white kids. Anybody who was a nuclear damn, your black kid would cost there, they would chase them back there. In the beginning, it was sort of like playing chicken. The thing was with them, it was the game. So, you know, and the black kids used to come, I think, for the same reason, you know,
安东尼·莫米诺在变化发生时还是个少年。他出生在突尼斯，但他是个意大利人。东纽约的许多白人都是意大利人。我记得我住的地方，大部分都是白人孩子。任何一个……你的黑人孩子如果经过那里，他们就会把他们赶回去。起初，这有点像是在玩胆小鬼游戏。对他们来说，这就是个游戏。所以，你知道，黑人孩子过去常来，我想，也是出于同样的原因，你知道……
let's get the white kids to chase'es. Think about how disorienting it was to be in East New York in the early 1960s. If you're white, you've seen your tight ethnic enclave flooded with newcomers. Your friends are gone. If you're black or Puerto Rican, you're moving in for the affordable rents, or the American dream of home ownership. You might have also migrated from the South to find a job and escape segregation. But now these cranky old timers are telling
让白人孩子去追他们。想想在20世纪60年代初身处东纽约是多么令人困惑。如果你是白人，你看到你紧密的族裔聚居区被新来者淹没。你的朋友走了。如果你是黑人或波多黎各人，你为了负担得起的租金，或者为了拥有住房的美国梦而搬进来。你可能也从南方迁移过来寻找工作并逃避种族隔离。但现在这些脾气暴躁的老家伙在告诉你……
you this ain't your place. And you're probably thinking, dude, if this neighborhood is so wonderful, why did all the white folks, all at once, like a herd of antelope, move to Long Island? I used to deliver the Brooklyn Eagle, and when I used to get the Broadway, I see one side of the street was black, and the other side of the street was white, and I couldn't understand that. Then when I was in junior high, we got two black girls and then that was a big thing going on, you know. I still didn't understand it.
这不是你的地方。你可能在想，伙计，如果这个社区这么好，为什么所有的白人，一下子，像一群羚羊一样，搬到了长岛？我过去常送《布鲁克林鹰报》，当我到达百老汇时，我看到街道的一边是黑人，另一边是白人，我不明白这一点。后来我在初中时，我们班来了两个黑人女孩，那是一件大事，你知道。我还是不明白。
Then I had a friend of mine live across the street when Dan Alabama, and he got beat up for the super reason. he got up and gave a black woman a seat and when he came back to Brooklyn he had two black guys. So yeah, race relations in the South were obviously not good, but in 1965 America was reminded in a big way. They're not good anywhere. This is a network news report from the time. August 11, 1965, the bloodiest riot in 40 years
然后我有一个朋友住在街对面，当他在阿拉巴马州时，他因为那个原因被打了。他站起来给一位黑人妇女让座，当他回到布鲁克林时，他有两个黑人朋友。所以，是的，南方的种族关系显然不好，但在1965年，美国以一种巨大的方式被提醒。它们在任何地方都不好。这是一份当时的电视新闻报道。1965年8月11日，40年来最血腥的骚乱……
of America's troubled racial history begins. Los Angeles, California, the district called once. 34 persons die, $40 million worth of property is destroyed. Almost 4,000 are arrested. The American Negro, the invisible man, breaks out in a screen. Look at me, look at me. Know me for what I am. Look at me if you can." So now it's a year after images of LA burning have lit up American TV screens. It's the start of the summer of 1966, and every major city is wondering, could the Watts riot
美国动荡的种族历史开始了。加利福尼亚州洛杉矶，那个被称为瓦茨（Watts）的地区。34人死亡，价值4000万美元的财产被毁。近4000人被捕。美国黑人，这个隐形人，在尖叫中爆发。“看着我，看着我。了解我的本质。如果可以的话，看着我。”所以现在距离洛杉矶燃烧的画面照亮美国电视屏幕已经一年了。1966年的夏天开始了，每个大城市都在想，瓦茨骚乱……
happen here? New York's new mayor, John Lindsay, is fixated on preventing it. Lindsay has been gathering a national reputation for walking the streets of New York at night without a security detail mostly in poor neighborhoods as a gesture of concern. Here's how he describes the tension in places like East New York. The city governments have been largely absent from the getters. Their chief presence, usually, has taken the form of a policeman. And it has been his unhappy launch to be the lone representative of the man, white people, the honkies, and by extension the entire public
会在这里发生吗？纽约新市长约翰·林赛（John Lindsay）专注于预防它。林赛因在夜间不带安保人员走在纽约街头（主要是贫困社区）而赢得了全国声誉，这是一种关心的姿态。以下是他描述像东纽约这样的地方的紧张局势的方式。市政府在贫民窟中基本缺席。他们的主要存在，通常以警察的形式出现。而他不幸的职责是成为“那个人”（白人，那些honkies）的唯一代表，进而代表整个公共……
and private establishment. Lindsay's chief of staff was Jay Kriegel, who was 26 at the time. Today he's a white-haired executive with the real estate giant related companies. His office has a powerbroker's view of Columbus Circle where he and I talked. When I emailed Kriegel to set up the interview, I asked if he remembered a particular incident from that summer of 1966. The shooting of an 11-year-old black boy named Eric Dean, he wrote back like it was yesterday. So this incident begins with a conflict over turf.
和私人机构。林赛的幕僚长是杰伊·克里格尔（Jay Kriegel），当时26岁。今天，他是一位白发苍苍的房地产巨头Related Companies的高管。他的办公室可以看到哥伦布圆环的权力经纪人视角，我和他就是在那里交谈的。当我给克里格尔发邮件安排采访时，我问他是否记得1966年那个夏天的一个特定事件。那个名叫埃里克·迪恩（Eric Dean）的11岁黑人男孩被枪杀的事件，他回信说得就像昨天发生的一样。所以这个事件始于一场关于地盘的冲突。
It's a classic turf battle of a something called a triangle right below the East New York subway station. And it's a battle between attacking kids who've always lived there. This is their turf and black kids who newly moving in. Shouting matches, fist fights, by all accounts, the neighborhood was on the verge of exploding. Lindsay decides to go out to East New York, which as you know is a long way away from City Hall because there's an eruption of violence between the two communities. And Lindsay and three of us race out there and go to a little pizza polla, which is right under the subway station where Lindsay meets with these kids.
这是一场经典的关于东纽约地铁站下方一个所谓的“三角形”地带的地盘之争。这是那些一直住在那里的攻击性孩子（这是他们的地盘）和新搬来的黑人孩子之间的战斗。叫喊声、拳脚相向，据所有人的说法，社区正处于爆炸的边缘。林赛决定去东纽约，你知道，那离市政厅很远，因为两个社区之间爆发了暴力冲突。林赛和我们三个人冲到那里，去了地铁站下面的一家小披萨店，林赛在那里会见了这些孩子。
Kriegel says the sit down at Frank's restaurant on New Lots Avenue goes well enough, except for the group of whites who march by shouting, two, four, six, eight, we don't want to integrate. Lindsay leaves around 10 p.m. and then the explosion happens. An account in the New York Times says about 30 whites from Spongebob. Remember Spongebob? The Society for the Prevention of Negroes getting everything? They start picketing at a traffic island behind police barricades. A group of black counter demonstrators form and the group's exchange words. Spongebob members burst through the barricades
克里格尔说，在New Lots大道Frank's餐厅的会谈进行得还算顺利，除了有一群白人游行经过，高喊着：“二、四、六、八，我们不想融合。”林赛在晚上10点左右离开，然后爆炸发生了。《纽约时报》的一篇报道称，大约30名来自Sponge的白人（还记得Sponge吗？“防止黑人获得一切协会”？）开始在警察路障后的交通岛上进行纠察。一群黑人反示威者形成，双方发生了口角。Sponge成员冲破路障……
and give chase. The groups don't physically clash, but a block away near a group of blacks, a gun goes off. A witness later tells a jury that nothing happens for a minute before, quote, a little boy stands up and lays down in the gutter. It's Eric Dean. He's taken away by ambulance and soon dies. The time says groups of black residents then roam the neighborhood, some throw garbage cans through store windows and bricks at police cars.
并进行追逐。双方并没有发生肢体冲突，但在一个街区外，靠近一群黑人的地方，枪声响了。一名目击者后来告诉陪审团，在……之前，什么都没发生，引用：“一个小男孩站起来，躺在排水沟里。”那是埃里克·迪恩。他被救护车带走，不久就死了。时报称，一群黑人居民随后在社区游荡，一些人把垃圾桶扔进商店窗户，并向警车投掷砖块。
The disturbance lasts about four hours. At City Hall the next day, Mary Lindsey calls his aides in and asks them who knows East New York, what's going on, who were the players. Jake Kriegel says everyone sort of looks at each other. Previous mayors could have gotten these answers quickly because previous mayors were Democrats. Lindsay is a Republican. The city had been run by Democratic mayors
骚乱持续了大约四个小时。第二天在市政厅，市长林赛召集他的助手，问他们谁了解东纽约，发生了什么，谁是参与者。杰伊·克里格尔说，每个人都面面相觑。以前的市长可以很快得到这些答案，因为以前的市长是民主党人。林赛是共和党人。这座城市一直由民主党市长管理……
using the Democratic machine. So the city wanted to know what was going on in East New York. It would call the local district leader and would call the local clubhouse. And that was really the city's branch office in these communities across the city. Kregel says this is why today we have community boards with professional staff.
利用民主党机器。所以市政府想知道东纽约发生了什么。它会打电话给当地的区领导，会打电话给当地的俱乐部。那确实是市政府在全市这些社区的分支机构。克里格尔说，这就是为什么今天我们有配备专业人员的社区委员会。
The boards existed in 1966, but they were voluntary and they were pretty sleepy. Lindsay beefed up their powers and gave them money. So he'd have locals on the ground to talk to when stuff hit the fan. Lindsay also oversaw a change in police tactics. Bringing the cops into the community early for in the afternoon, rather than 9 o'clock at night in the dark. Instead of cops running down the streets in the dark, we're there scared because they
这些委员会在1966年就存在了，但它们是自愿的，而且相当沉寂。林赛加强了他们的权力并给了他们资金。这样当事情爆发时，他就有当地人在地面上可以交谈。林赛还监督了警察战术的改变。让警察在下午早些时候进入社区，而不是在晚上9点天黑时。警察不是在黑暗中在街上奔跑，因为他们……
don't know where they are. The people are scared to see an army marching in. Cops come in the daylight, they stand around, they talk to people, they get acclimated, they see what's around and the people get acclimated to them. Krigel says cops were instructed to leave their night sticks at the precincts, to not use force, and to not stand on rooftops with rifles. Those tactics helped calm East New York.
不知道自己在哪里，他们很害怕。人们看到一支军队行进进来也很害怕。警察在白天进来，他们站在周围，与人交谈，他们适应环境，他们看到周围的情况，人们也适应了他们。克里格尔说，警察被指示把警棍留在警局，不要使用武力，也不要站在屋顶上拿着步枪。这些战术帮助平息了东纽约。
Besides Eric Dean, no one died that summer during public unrest. A local black teenager was later charged with the dean shooting and put on trial, but a jury acquitted him. In the end, Lindsey managed to keep New York relatively free from the major fires and fatal racial violence that ignited around the country in places like Newark and Detroit and other cities. But within a year, almost every single white family moved away from East New York. White flight then spread through neighborhoods around the city, especially the outer burrows. But the turf wars between teenagers were just one symptom of a larger process that was unfolding.
除了埃里克·迪恩，那个夏天在公共骚乱中没有人死亡。一名当地黑人少年后来被指控枪杀迪恩并受审，但陪审团判他无罪。最终，林赛设法使纽约相对免于在全国各地（如纽瓦克、底特律和其他城市）点燃的大规模火灾和致命的种族暴力。但在一年之内，几乎每一个白人家庭都搬离了东纽约。白人逃离随后蔓延到全市的社区，尤其是外围行政区。但青少年之间的地盘之争只是正在展开的更大过程的一个症状。
Whites and blacks were in conflict, but they were being pitted against each other by much larger forces. Brooklyn was in the process of absorbing two great migrations. Southern blacks coming north in search of industrial jobs, and Puerto Ricans fleeing the decimated economy of the island. But segregation limited these migrants' housing options. So Black and Puerto Rican neighborhoods like Bedstuy and Harlem quickly became overcrowded. People began desperately searching for places to live. And landlords and real estate investors saw opportunity in that desperation. They hone two tactics that have shaped neighborhoods
白人和黑人之间存在冲突，但他们被更大的力量相互对立。布鲁克林正在吸收两次大移民。南方黑人向北寻找工业工作，波多黎各人逃离岛上崩溃的经济。但种族隔离限制了这些移民的住房选择。因此，像贝德斯图（Bed-Stuy）和哈莱姆（Harlem）这样的黑人和波多黎各社区迅速变得过度拥挤。人们开始拼命寻找居住的地方。房东和房地产投资者在那种绝望中看到了机会。他们磨练了两种塑造社区的战术……
all over the country ever since. Fear-induced white flight and predatory lending. You can sell your home as is, all cash, at no cost to you, and your home can be sold fast. Even if you're facing four corners, you lose. Here's how it worked. It started in the years after World War II, and a stretch of tenements on the neighborhoods Western Edge.
从那以后，全国各地都是如此。恐惧诱导的白人逃离和掠夺性贷款。你可以按原样出售你的房子，全现金，无需你支付任何费用，你的房子可以快速售出。即使你面临四面楚歌，你也会输。它是这样运作的。它始于二战后的几年，在社区西缘的一片公寓楼里。
The white families who lived there were already frustrated with the landlords neglect. Owners wanted to do the least and get the most out of these buildings. But something larger was about to play out. We were very much afraid of the atomic bomb. This is Ron Schiffman again, the urban planner who's been working in Central Brooklyn since the 60s. And that's right, Brooklyn since the 60s. And that's right, he said that Adam Baum, the fear during the Cold War permeated American
住在那里白人家庭已经对房东的忽视感到沮丧。业主想在这些建筑上投入最少，获得最多。但更大的事情即将上演。我们非常害怕原子弹。这又是罗恩·希夫曼，那位自60年代以来一直在中布鲁克林工作的城市规划师。没错，自60年代以来就在布鲁克林。没错，他说那个原子弹，冷战期间的恐惧渗透到了美国……
policy. Coming out of World War II, the policy of the federal government was the dispersed essential populations to allow people to move out of the cities, to allow manufacturing and essential industries to move out of the cities. So white tenants were giving it out. The feds began subsidizing mortgages in highways and what became a wildly successful effort to create a new class of suburban homeowners, but only for those essential populations.
政策中。二战结束后，联邦政府的政策是分散核心人口，允许人们搬出城市，允许制造业和核心产业搬出城市。所以白人租户被赶走了。联邦政府开始补贴抵押贷款和高速公路，这在创造新一代郊区房主方面取得了巨大的成功，但仅限于那些核心人口。
Essential populations were considered to be white and educated and wealthy. And all of the major real estate lobby groups advocated for restricting black buyers from the loans and neighborhoods that our public dollars financed. In East New York, white renters seized upon the chance to buy homes.
核心人口被认为是白人、受过教育且富有的人。所有主要的房地产游说团体都主张限制黑人买家获得贷款和我们公共资金资助的社区。在东纽约，白人租户抓住了购买房屋的机会。
And the landlords were happy to see them go. They've been a pain in the butt, and now there are all of these black and Puerto Rican renters who faced a housing shortage and could be price-couged. But it didn't stop there. The real opportunity that segregation offered for real estate speculators was in flipping the houses that East New York's Italian and German and Jewish immigrants had owned for years.
房东很高兴看到他们离开。他们一直是个麻烦，现在有这么多面临住房短缺并可能被哄抬价格的黑人和波多黎各租户。但这并没有停止。种族隔离为房地产投机者提供的真正机会在于倒卖东纽约的意大利、德国和犹太移民多年来拥有的房屋。
But to make a profit off of that, they had to get those white homeowners to sell for cheap. People would come in literally and hire somebody to go out on the street and get into a fight in front of your house, all right, to scare you from leaving. So that you'd feel like there's violence in the neighborhood. There were even pamphlets put out that were attributed to black people. When you read them, it was obviously written by a white pretending to be such. And they would say what? what would the flyers say? You know, we're gonna get whitey because of this
但要从中获利，他们必须让那些白人房主廉价出售。人们会真的进来，雇人去街上，在你家门前打架，好吧，吓唬你离开。这样你就会觉得社区里有暴力。甚至还有归咎于黑人的传单。当你读它们时，显然是白人假装成黑人写的。他们会说，什么？传单会说什么？你知道，我们要因为这个……
or something or other. There was scare tactics going on. There were people coming in and basically saying that if you don't sell, you're going to lose the value of your home. They would just show up and knock on the door and say, hey, they went and solicited door to door, knocked on the door in a way
或者其他什么东西去对付白人。有恐吓战术在进行。有人进来，基本上说如果你不卖，你就会失去房子的价值。他们会直接出现并敲门说，嘿，他们挨家挨户地游说，敲门……
saying, we're willing to buy your house for all cash today. You may not get this tomorrow. What we now think of as white flight began in East New York. Remember one person she had a house up on 4 Bell Street. Again, Tony Momina. They came one day yesterday when it's so she says, no, they came the next day, you want to sell. She says, no, after about a week, they get up in the morning and the front door is on the floor. A little something to focus the woman's mind on the offer. The next day, the buyer's returned. So she
说，我们今天愿意全现金买你的房子。你明天可能得不到这个价格。我们现在所认为的“白人逃离”始于东纽约。记得一个人，她在4 Bell街有一栋房子。又是安东尼·莫米诺。他们有一天来了，她说不，他们第二天又来了，你想卖吗？她说不，大约一周后，他们早上起来，前门就在地板上了。给那个女人的头脑一点东西来关注这个提议。第二天，买家回来了。所以她……
want to sell now, this they took the money and ran. This is blockbusting and it worked. While teens fought in the streets, their parents fought over property. And the blockbusting, it set up the next stage in the process for real estate investors, predatory lending. They set up these fast foreclosures schemes, where they would buy cheaper from the white families, resell it at a higher price to African American and Latino families. The aspiring black or Latino homeowner would sign a contract with the investor, but the arrangement would look a lot like those rent to own deals on appliances today. They'd be on the hook for way too much money, more than they could afford, and more than
现在想卖了吗？他们拿了钱就跑了。这就是“街区破坏”（blockbusting），而且奏效了。当青少年在街上打架时，他们的父母在为财产而战。而街区破坏为房地产投资者设置了过程的下一阶段：掠夺性贷款。他们设立了这些快速止赎计划，他们以更低的价格从白人家庭买入，以更高的价格转售给非裔和拉丁裔家庭。有抱负的黑人或拉丁裔房主会与投资者签署合同，但这种安排看起来很像今天家电的“租购”交易。他们会背负太多的钱，超过他们能负担的，也超过……
the house was worth. After two to three months, they couldn't make their payments, so they finally moved to evict them, and within a year or two, they evicted them, and they had the housing back in their own hands and sold them again. So they churned these buildings. Wait, are you talking about the 60s or the early 2000s at our foreclosure crisis? That sounds very similar to the subprice. It is very similar.
房子本身的价值。两三个月后，他们付不起钱，所以他们最终搬去驱逐他们，在一两年内，他们驱逐了他们，他们又把房子拿回自己手中，再次出售。所以他们不断倒卖这些建筑。等等，你在说60年代还是2000年代初我们的止赎危机？这听起来很像次贷。确实很像。
It is very similar. It was very similar. Throughout all of this, racial tensions, of course, emerged. They always blamed each other for what happened. Primarily, the white families blamed the blacks who moved into the neighborhood for the abandonment and the decay of the neighborhood
确实很像。它非常相似。在这一切过程中，种族紧张局势当然出现了。他们总是互相指责发生的事情。主要是，白人家庭指责搬进社区的黑人导致了社区的荒废和衰败……
when it was really the real estate manipulation going on behind the scenes. This played out in fights between teenagers. Those fights blossomed in the gang wars. The summers of 1966 and 1967 were marred by conflict. And then Eric Dean got shot and killed. By the end of 1967, Barod Swass of East New York were as much as 97% black and Puerto Rican. Today, Tony is in the same house, but he says he can count the other whites in the surrounding area on one hand.
而实际上是幕后的房地产操纵。这在青少年之间的打斗中表现出来。那些打斗演变成了帮派战争。1966年和1967年的夏天被冲突所破坏。然后埃里克·迪恩被枪杀身亡。到1967年底，东纽约的街区多达97%是黑人和波多黎各人。今天，托尼还在同一栋房子里，但他说是他可以一只手就数清周围的其他白人。
He watched them move one after another over the decades. Either the Howard Beach or Al Thalong Island. I don't know if people will help a beach or better than where I am, but the whole thing is they have the name Howard Beach. A lot of people are afraid to say East New York, when somebody asks me, I tell them East New York, I'm proud of it.
他看着他们几十年来一个接一个地搬走。要么去霍华德海滩（Howard Beach），要么去长岛。我不知道人们是否认为海滩比我住的地方好，但重点是他们有“霍华德海滩”这个名字。很多人害怕说“东纽约”，当有人问我时，我告诉他们东纽约，我为此感到自豪。
That pride is not a small matter when it comes to neighborhood development. In the decades after Eric Dean was killed when public and private investment drained out of the place, the real difference between the dark stereotypes of East New York and the reality of community has been residents sheer well. Tony retired from driving delivery trucks 33 years ago. He spent most of that time volunteering at Cypress Hills local development corporation.
当涉及到社区发展时，这种自豪感并非小事。在埃里克·迪恩被杀后的几十年里，当公共和私人投资从这个地方流失时，东纽约的黑暗刻板印象与社区现实之间的真正区别在于居民纯粹的意志。托尼33年前从驾驶送货卡车退休。他大部分时间都在赛普拉斯山（Cypress Hills）当地发展公司做志愿者。
He's been part of dozens of initiatives, from watchdogging the local police precinct to working with banks to fund building projects. And he's not alone. Harold Green and his wife moved here in 1978 when they bought a house up on the hill by Highland Park and what is still one of the tonier parts of the neighborhood. It was nice. It was very nice.
他参与了数十项倡议，从监督当地警察分局到与银行合作资助建筑项目。他并不孤单。哈罗德·格林（Harold Green）和他的妻子在1978年搬到这里，当时他们在高地公园（Highland Park）旁的山上买了一栋房子，那里仍然是社区中比较高档的部分之一。那很好。非常好。
It was very quiet. It was transportation accessible. And the price, the price was very affordable at the time, and we have a nice two-family house. By the early 80s, he was volunteering at the development corporation with Tony. One of my neighbors was on the board of the Cypress Hills, and she kept insisting how do you come down and you know, like volunteer your time. So, you know, I came, you know, being in management and social services.
它非常安静。交通便利。而且价格，价格在当时非常实惠，我们有一栋不错的双家庭住宅。到80年代初，他开始和托尼一起在发展公司做志愿者。我的一个邻居是赛普拉斯山董事会的成员，她一直坚持让我过来，你知道，像志愿贡献你的时间。所以，你知道，我来了，你知道，在管理和社会服务方面。
I had some communication skills and I also had some financial back, so it worked out. Today, long retired, he's the board chair. He drove me around and showed me some of the stuff they've built during the years of divestment, a grade school with a green house on top. Three and four-story apartment buildings with affordable units, senior housing for which they've just broken ground.
我有沟通技巧，也有财务背景，所以效果很好。今天，早已退休的他担任董事会主席。他开车带我四处看看，向我展示了他们在撤资期间建造的一些东西：一所屋顶上有温室的小学。三四层高的公寓楼，带有经济适用房单元，他们刚刚为老年人住房破土动工。
You have to do for your community because no one else would do for you. And now, like most other property owners here, he's got mixed feelings about the city's plan to spur more development. He's more than happy to see the new resources and even eager to see new people with their new money. It's just, well, what will happen then? We've been watching from Williamsburg up through Ford Green Bushwick, so we are aware of
你必须为你的社区做点什么，因为没有其他人会为你做。现在，像这里大多数其他业主一样，他对市政府刺激更多发展的计划心情复杂。他很高兴看到新的资源，甚至渴望看到带着新钱的新人。只是，嗯，那会发生什么呢？我们一直在观察从威廉斯堡（Williamsburg）到福特格林（Fort Greene）、布什维克（Bushwick），所以我们意识到……
what's happening and we're just trying to position ourselves to get the best results and the best response from the city administration to make, help make each New York Cypress Hills, Broadway junctions, surrounding areas as vibrant, as safe, and as livable as possible. But you know, for guys like Tony, it's been livable for a long time. Why did you never move? Oh, I can move. My son's got a big house up in Newberg that I could have moved there. You know, no problem.
正在发生什么，我们只是试图定位自己，以从市政府获得最好的结果和最好的回应，以帮助使东纽约、赛普拉斯山、百老汇枢纽（Broadway Junction）及周边地区尽可能充满活力、安全和宜居。但你知道，对于像托尼这样的人来说，它已经宜居很长时间了。你为什么从来没搬走？哦，我可以搬。我儿子在纽堡（Newberg）有一栋大房子，我本可以搬到那里的。你知道，没问题。
Everything on the main floor and everything. But what am I going to do there? Once a day watch the amadella go across the grounds to drink the water. You know, that's the most exciting. And over here we have a little shooting, we have a little car accident, you know. You get to go outside, talk to the people, you know, different views. I still don't understand this black and white thing, different, you know, I treat people as they treat me."
主楼层上的一切，什么都有。但我去那里做什么？一天一次看着羚羊穿过场地去喝水。你知道，那是最高兴的事。而在这里，我们有一点枪击，我们有一点车祸，你知道。你可以出去，和人们交谈，你知道，不同的观点。我还是不明白这个黑白问题，不同的，你知道，我对待别人就像他们对待我一样。”
This black and white thing, we're still talking about it, and we're hearing about it in every neighborhood we visit with this podcast. It comes up with foreclosure and the history of racially targeted subprime lending. It comes up with the demographic shifts people are seeing now, and it explains a lot of the anxieties people have about the city's redevelopment plan for places like East New York. Because after generations of flipping, of blockbusting to chase out whites, predatory lending to bring in blacks and Latinos, and decades of abandonment that followed.
这个黑白问题，我们还在谈论它，我们在用这个播客访问的每个社区都听到它。它出现在止赎和种族针对性次级贷款的历史中。它出现在人们现在看到的人口结构变化中，它解释了人们对市政府针对东纽约等地方的重建计划的许多焦虑。因为经过几代人的倒卖、为了赶走白人的街区破坏、为了引入黑人和拉丁裔的掠夺性贷款，以及随之而来的几十年的荒废。
People are skeptical of manufactured change. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background,
人们对人为制造的变化持怀疑态度。[♪ 背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，
playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, the Nation magazine. Recorded and mixed by Casey Means, research by Sean Carlson and Anakwa Dramina. Digital production by Lee Hill, Delaney Simmons, Kevin France, Frank Roberts, and Annie Shields. It was reported and produced by DWI Gibson, Rebecca Carroll, Jim O'Grady, and Chi Wright, and edited and executive produced by Karen Frelman. You can hear the rest of this series and you really should, it's just fantastic, at wnyc.org slash neighborhood.
背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，《国家》杂志。由凯西·米恩斯（Casey Means）录制和混音，肖恩·卡尔森（Sean Carlson）和阿纳夸·德拉米纳（Anakwa Dramina）研究。数字制作由李·希尔（Lee Hill）、德莱尼·西蒙斯（Delaney Simmons）、凯文·弗朗斯（Kevin France）、弗兰克·罗伯茨（Frank Roberts）和安妮·希尔兹（Annie Shields）完成。由DWI吉布森（DWI Gibson）、丽贝卡·卡罗尔（Rebecca Carroll）、吉姆·奥格雷迪（Jim O'Grady）和凯·赖特（Chi Wright）报道和制作，由凯伦·弗雷尔曼（Karen Frelman）编辑和执行制作。你可以在wnyc.org/neighborhood收听这个系列的其余部分，你真的应该听听，它太棒了。
99% invisible is Sam Greenspan, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, Sheree Views F and me Roman Mars. Intro and outro music this week by our friends O.K. Akumi on Hell Audio that's Utah's finest, electronic and experimental music label. We are a project of the 9-1.7KALW San Francisco and produced of the offices of ArcSund, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown, highly desirable, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. You can follow us all on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world
《99%隐形》的成员有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、谢丽·维尤斯·F（Sheree Views F）和我罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。本周的片头和片尾音乐来自我们的朋友O.K. Akumi on Hell Audio，那是犹他州最好的电子和实验音乐厂牌。我们是9-1.7 KALW旧金山的一个项目，在美丽的、市中心的、非常令人向往的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市的ArcSund建筑和室内设计事务所办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。你可以在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，但探索塑造我们世界设计的99%隐形活动的最好方式……
is to become friends with our website, it's 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. Radio Tepi-O. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是成为我们网站的朋友，网址是99pi.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。Radio Tepi-O。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。